hey come on nice push it baby you are a
god come on
this is chases assistant I'm bringing
him in now oh we need two more minutes
we try to get his picks to pop he's 13
I think his pecs can pop and why does he
suddenly need pecs because Brooke but we
did sweet we did gay now he's a boy
you don't call him that what clinched
you crap I wanted to have to fight its
way out come on this guy sucks I can't
believe I have to have sex with him you
don't know he's very dumb and very hot
so unfortunately I do good all right
guys may trees dreams
hey make sure he's wearing a bracelet
this is chases assistant I'm bringing
him now and we actually decided necklace
I love having a walkie
how you doing you're excited I'm so
nervous I can barf I just hope I don't
mess up tonight don't be nervous you
literally can't mess up watch what
happens like we still have you next to
me behind you but yeah it'll be nice to
hang out I feel like I've been so busy
since you know dear okay I gotta run
you're so lucky you don't wear clothes
tonight yes I feel very very lucky hi um
I'm looking to get jacked fast do you
have a gym membership
no but it's kind of an emergency I'm
gonna be the bartender on watch what
happens live cuz it's just it's good to
be seen yeah yeah no totally I did that
last week oh are you an actor - yeah
oh no I met Andy at a rag and bone and
who's asked me oh good good good okay
you're chilling on your car yeah you're
loving your watch put a little closer
your face okay like do it naturally hold
it like you'd hold your watch close to
your face on your car
god
oh my god Brooke to you back
Genevieve Kim we used to dance together
at SAV oh hi yeah are you dancing in
your brother's video I thought you
stopped after you broke your ankle long
time ago yeah I did
I'm actually here because I'm I'm his
I'm his manager
yeah I'm a really big-time manager now
that is so cool yeah my life is very
cool I don't know why they gave us to a
manager anyway how are you I saw on
Facebook you did a gig in Paris yeah so
fun but it was really rainy no no no it
was really really sunny
anybody got eyes on chases assistant I
repeat we have a track emergency where
is this dumb bitch bro why'd you walk
you on the ground the car you all sit we
have a snack emergency I'm gonna head
back to holding the choreographer is a
disaster just be glad you don't have to
deal with that anymore right Amina then
you don't have to deal with that anymore
asshole
[Music]
pardon me sir
I think this was broken
[Music]
it's been one minute
you have a great day as well finished
already huh no no no I just thought
there might be some I thought there
might be heavier weights out here all
right hello but I'm just gonna make do
with the lighter ones that are inside
you hiding from the weights 2k beer
Lance okay we don't know what some of
these products are actually gonna be yet
so just pretend you're watching the
coolest movie that you've ever seen now
it's a scary movie now it's a funny
movie now it's a dating website now it's
a Christian dating website yep all right
check the gate on whatever that was turn
around let's hit chase for wardrobe
excuse me Genevieve oh hey Brooke I was
just telling the girls how I used to
dance I know you were saying that you're
so much better than me because I'm my
little brother's assistant you're still
dancing in Paris while it's sunny well
guess what I might not be a dancer
anymore but I'm happy yeah because I
have purpose I have direction and most
importantly my toes are back to normal
so you take them oh my god your toes are
that bad
you